- Ahhh.
- Flat tire.
- Yeah, I mean I can call my insurance--
- Same.
- They'll be here in no time.
- No service.
- Yeah me neither.
I mean we can change a tire.
- Yeah, yeah, I change tires all the time.
- Yeah I know how to change a tire.
(upbeat electronic music)
There should be some kind of lever.
Ah, there we go!
- Where's the tire?
- You know what, how about
you get started on the tire,
I'll go check the engine and
make sure this puppy's running.
Yeah, the flux capacitor is all messed up.
- Do you think the hard drive crashed?
- The hard drive looks good,
it's the soft drive that's making me mad.
- Did you check the flask thindle?
- Do you have a slam rod?
- No, only a twist pole.
- Are you Lightning the McQueen?
- Yeah, why do you think I
asked for the twist pole?
When was the last time you
put Vin Diesel in this?
- Did you Damon the Affleck?
- Do you have a jalopy bible?
I feel like this would be a lot easier.
- I don't think so.
- God, if you could just
please fix this car,
it'd be really solid of you.
- Get us out of this mess,
I'll never do anything bad again, I swear.
I found the rubber wheel!
- What kinda car is this?
- A '67 Ford Coppola.
- That's what I thought. Damn it!
- Zach, are you eating grass?
- I didn't have breakfast!
So sorry if I'm a little hangry!
- Just a couple of oil buddies!
- A couple dirty gas parrots!
- This tire Y2K or B2K?
- You think we should
just 76 the Chevron shop?
Do you wanna go halfsies
in opening a shop with me?
- Absolutely!
(vomits)
- Alright, I think I'm going
to cut the umbilical cord.
- Ooh, make sure you don't
cut the fallopian tube.
- I won't!
Can you just press the
car button real quick?
- Car button, car button
- Okay, now take it out of DRIV,
put it into PAUSE.
- Do you want me to
release the stop stick?
- Car's totaled.
- Snap out of it, man!
Snap out of it!
- No no no no no no no no no no!
You know what's the problem?
You drive too much Cruise control.
- Oh, that's Risky Business.
- Is it about to Rain, Man?
- I dunno, looks like Vanilla Sky to me.
- This Mission's Impossible.
- Maybe I should file a Minority Report.
- Or how about we just keep
it under Ghost Protocol?
- Keep your Eyes Wide Shut,
we're gonna figure this out.
- You know what, you're
right, we're A Few Good Men.
You ever think about
what kinda wedding dress
your wife's gonna wear one day?
(sighs)
- Every day.
- Why are we stuck right now?
Please just fix the car, God!
- Take me, God! Bring me up to heaven now!
- Hang in there!
We're going to make it out of this, okay?
(celestial singing)
- I love you, man.
(car drives by)
- [Newscaster] Ladies and gentlemen,
we interrupt this program to
bring you some breaking news.
Two men were recently found
dead on the side of the road
after experiencing some car trouble.
The shocking thing is,
they were exactly .2 miles
away from the nearest gas station.
Back to you, Chris!
(upbeat metallic rock)